I'M ALMOST THERE I'M ALMOST THERE
I'm almost-
YEAHHHHHH!!!!
[ SUSPENSE MUSIC ]
Aw shit--fuck, not again--- awh, its-
Super... l-
So late..
I haven't recorded a video
I record a video everyday
Why? (TRIGGEREDNOISES)
God dammit, I'm fucked.
I'm gonna have to find a game REAL fast!
I won't make that adsense. Fuck
Surely, I haven't done a game-play in a while
surely there's a game out there just for me!
No, for fuck's sake!
I said a real game!
Hotoful- I've PLAYED that!
Wait..
Wait a minute..
Wait a minute!
What is this?
Gal*Gun: Double Peace..
*Orgasm*
Wow!
This is great!
Thishshs
This one, this one, I'll play this one!
I think I'm gonna play this one...
yeah, oh definitely I'll play this one!
So there's a panic button...
And if you hit it...
[ VOICE IN THE VIDEO ] "Oh, wha-what am I doing? Nothing, nothing Mom"
It switches to an RPG!
That's fucking beautiful!
Anyway uh, while we wait for this game to download
I just wanna say.. thank you
for leaving a like on this video!
[ SAD DISTORTED MUSIC ]
oh FUCK yeah!
I'm going to Minasha Bliss dance on this one..
[ Minasha ]: Hi I'm Rinasha Bliss and I'm your freestyle dance teacher
[ Pewds ]: Help!!
What kind of person are you?
I'm a bookworm, jock, fashionista, pervert..
Pervert! 100%!
Alright..
How does that affect the game?Who knows..
Who cares?
Let's play!
[ READS DIALOG ON SCREEN ]
Ho-how? Oh shit
Ok, I literally don't care.. Just skip!
That's a gshhshshh, cute!
Not as cute as Marzia though!
[ PEWDS PULLING OFF  MARZIA'S VOICE ] Felix?
What are you playing?
Hey, Ma-Marzia!
It's an RPG!
End button..
End button!
It doesn't work!!
Dammit!
oogh, I love when the music changes..
Potential love interest?
Can't stop... dancing
There better be boobs real fucking fast!
or else..
They're not goinna watch long enough for a mid-roll! Come on..
What has happened
Is she gonna jump?
What kind of game is this?
Do it!
Do it! Sorry, sorry I just reflexed..
Oh..
Oh my godI think it's starting!
What is happening?
What is this?
Oh my god what happened? What happened?
I wanna know what happened!!
You're awake.
oHHHH
What do I do?
Ecstacy Shot!
What?!
I just keep shooting them?!
Why am I shooting them!?
YEaHhH
I see how it is..
Ecstasy shots!
I can zoom!!
*KAZOOOOOOO*
Japanese people must have the patience...
how do they say it through this much text?
I don't understand...
I mean yes I have AD--
Clearly have ADHD but this is DIFFERENT.
Don't see them young that's just weird!
I don't know- No, you're ruining it, you were great
now you ruined it!
Now you ruined it..
Fuck!
Ok, so what do I do?
I zoom in..
Analize..
Oh, I analyzed!
And then what?
Oh!!
My!!
God!
No!
No, I can't play this game!
I can't..
I can look at her shoes..
those are great shoes..
So her tits are her weakness..
What do I do then?
OhHhH
Myyy
God! GodGodGodGodGodGodGodGodGod
What is happening?
What am I doing?
I'm clicking at her shoes Marzia!
oooooh my God!
[ SAD PIANO MUSIC ]
You know I- I actually cum the same way..
[ Triggered sad music ]
You know it's just in the heat of the moment..
I can't help myself..
Hngya!
Haaaaa!!
I got great fingers!
Nope!
Okay,  well we're playing now..
Got 'em
Let's zoom in on this one
Alright we want to shoot there
okay got it
Oh, we see through their clothing
Oh my god I see through the bushes
I mean I see that there's the bushes and
as the from the
bushes? Am I right?
Sorry
Alright so anyone hiding
Snipe 'em
I'm quick scoping these bitches
Bamm
It's literally. It just hit me it's
like one of thos-s-e arcade shooters
It literally is like an arcade shooter (giggles)
But you replace the zombies and monsters
With na- (stops self)
W.. With with japanese schoolgirls
It's genius
oh my god ready get to jet oh my god whOOP!
Oh my god there is more
Aw, that one is tiny
I don't know what I..
*Music Stops*
Feel about that.
I don't..
it's a weird balance
I don't know if
Felix!!
Oh, this RPG is the best
Happyface
I've been loving up happy face for a long time
Okay Felix
I
*Marzia Speak*
Oh boy, that was a close one
You just hit M
Fucking beautiful
This game is the best game
This game
it's my safe place
this is where I go when bad things happen
I want this game played at my funeral
I want a 16 player LAN setup
Where  everyone just plays this game
And thinks about me
actually, you know what?
They can just play the game, they don't-
oh my god oh my god what's happening
I am not recording that's what's happening
are you fucking kidding me
Whoooo
My God
Did you see the sheer panic
Alright
Tits, let's shooter in the tits
I realise how that sounds but ok I didn't make the game
I didn't make the game dammit
Why she running around in the bathingsuit
You know what, nevermind
Ah, Jesus christ
That actually scared me
Oo, I got an acheiv
*inaudible screeching*
Jesus
Twins
Oh, my god, hello
Shoot them once
You look at  their underwear ohmygod ohmygod
Don't show that
So do I kill them or do they just disapear
G rank :D
More like
*spot em*
Okay
I just wanna say I'm sorry about this video I don't even
I had to pick a game I just went with what
I had and here we are
that's right i see all you hoes
this game is practically my oh my god i could
unlock the fucking outfit and I missed it
come on scan where are they where they
come on headshot headshot
Fucking die
Sorry too far
Oh my god teacher
Sensei shot
fuck yeah i think i might be a little
too into this game at this point god
god i'm gonna
Headshot
Boob shot
yeah front shot
Ah, god
Dammit
I wanna  play this with like a giant purple
dildo in my hand
felix what the fuck why would you want that
don't quote me on that
But wouldn't it be cool
Sorry
*yeah you better be*
*Releases Inner Weeaboo*
was that cool
was that cool?
How much was this game?
how much did I pay for this?
I'm just, thirty bucks huh well I think the only
thing other question is is there a dlc
oh my fucking are you telling me you are
you telling me i could pay four pounds for
the wedding dress costume set
oh my fucking god Jesus Christ where is
my wallet I want to know what they're
saying if anyone of you speak Japanese
please translate
Did she fucking punch me?
Oh god oh my god yes senpai
Yes please
Wait what whoa whoa whoa what did i do
OHH
MY GOD
OH MY GOD
OH
THREEEEEEEE
THREE OF THEM
I'm
Oh noo
Ooo ,yeah the guilt
*someone fckin end his life already, why does he have to suffer with mental disease*
how do I do it
Where do you like it
where do you- oh she likes it there.
*close your eyes and just imagineeeeeeee* okay fuck it's hard
Ehh
Come on
I can't  please you all i'm just going to focus
on one of you. NO i'm almost there
almost there i'm almost yEEEES
yeah satisfaction
yeah that's what I'm talking about
that's how we do it
Oh, bitch exploding (?????)
*fingers his bottom part for extreme satisfaction*
Felix
Oh
Yeah Marzia, I'm on a boss battle
Hey you need to come now Felix
But I haven't
I haven't done my outro yet
check out this video it's very similar
to this one if you like this video you
might like like this one
Felix
okay I'm coming
I mean, uhm
Okay..